I think we can now firmly conclude that
this issue of the classified documents
has nothing to do with principle it has
nothing to do with real National
Security threats it is simply about
punishing political enemies
Hillary does it Hillary does the worst
version of it no big deal no slap on the
wrist doesn't matter Biden does a pretty
bad version of it no big deal brushing
under the rug nothing to see her move
along Move Along Donald Trump does the
version of it that is most defensible
and
hardest to claim is illegal in any way
it's the end of the world Americans are
being killed overseas we're giving away
the nuclear secrets this man needs to go
into an orange jumpsuit
and and now that this happened to Biden
you're going to see the news move right
along no big deal nothing to see here
okay this is just about punishing
political enemies you know this is the
case because the White House is dodging
questions on this issue like Neo in The
Matrix okay the Korean Jean-Pierre poor
lady I hope she can I hope she can bend
to the side the right way because the
questions are pretty straightforward the
issue is pretty clear and she is dodging
them as fast as she can on these
documents how could anyone be that
irresponsible isn't that what this
President says about mishandling
classified documents the president spoke
to this personally he spoke to this
personally he again he believes that
classified documents and information
should be taken seriously he takes them
seriously and he was surprised to learn
by any any records I disagree I disagree
here's what happened here's what
happened once the history of justice
department well let me let me explain to
you the process here's what happened
when his lawyers found out that the
documents were there they immediately
turn them over to their archives how can
President Biden be trusted moving
forward with American Secrets because
his lawyers his team did the right thing
but he had a closet with he classified
employers did the right again again
again he did he was surprised that the
records were there he spoke to this
personally he was surprised at the that
the records were there and when his
lawyers found out and his team found out
that they were there they turned it over
to their archives and now it's being
reviewed by the Department of Justice
oh he was surprised that the records
were there
okay then okay then no big deal
do I believe that Joe Biden was actually
surprised that the records were there
maybe he's a liar so I'm inclined not to
believe him but he's pretty forgetful so
I'm somewhat inclined to believe him
either way though he was surprised that
the records were there is no excuse
intention can matter when we're talking
about Prosecuting crimes
but if the action that is taken
intentionally or unintentionally is an
egregious action if it's against the law
then there has to be some punishment for
it right for the action itself not
merely the intention the road to hell is
paved with good intentions think about
the distinction between murder and
manslaughter yes it's true that we
prosecute murder more severely than we
prosecute manslaughter but we prosecute
manslaughter why because it's wrong to
kill a person whether you intend to kill
a person or not so is it wrong to
mishandle these classified documents or
is it not
well he just he didn't he didn't intend
to ignorance of the law is not an excuse
ignorance of your own actions is not an
excuse either not ultimately and so
you're going to see the libs move on
from this
and it's going to expose what the Trump
classified documents episode the walls
are closing in they've got him now of
2022 was really all about it was just a
bunch of nonsense to punish a political
enemy in fact
not only are you going to see these
sorts of excuses for Joe Biden's
Behavior you already are seeing them and
you're not just seeing them from his
paid spokesman you're not already seeing
them from
just from the White House Press
Secretary you're seeing them from The
Establishment media you are seeing it
from Joy Behar on The View on The View
joy joy Vejar on The View Joy Behar on
The View
says that this situation with Biden
improperly storing classified documents
it's completely different from what
Donald Trump did here's why
Barney's calmed down a little bit
because there are some perhaps
differences here the Optics are not
necessarily the best
so is it good news for you know who
anything that makes us talk about him is
good news for him not really I mean I I
think that no matter what you just said
is right that there are differences in
what happened yes it's not good well we
all know that Trump is a liar and a
thief you know we know that
so it's not that big a jump to say that
he obstructed and he lied we don't think
that Biden is a liar and a thief so we
give him the benefit of the doubt that's
probably what's going on
that's what's going on right now I know
I know people are going to
pull their hair out in indignation and
shock at the absurdity of Joy behar's
statement that Joe Biden he's not a liar
and a thief
job put thieving aside I mean he seems
pretty crooked to me but he is a liar
he's probably the most infamous liar
politician alive today
not a cheap shot I'm not just trying to
throw a bomb at my political opponent I
mean specifically for lying he's been
caught in it the most he's had the most
political consequence in his life
because he's a liar Democrats call him a
lie Republicans call him a Liars but put
that aside for a second the principle
that Joy Behar is espousing here is
we give more grace to people on our own
side than we do to our enemies and to
our political opponents
that's a pretty smart principle actually
there's nothing wrong with that
principle
there's nothing hypocritical
it's not that there's a double standard
even with that kind of a principle
that is politics
politics is a team sport
politics begins with the premise that
man is a social animal and we find our
identity and our flourishing in society
with one another and when you're in
Democratic politics and Republican
politics such as we are then there are
going to be different coalitions that
form to get things done no man is an
island you can't do politics all by
yourself and so you form coalitions and
it is Perfectly Natural to have more
trust in the people who are close to you
it is Perfectly Natural to give the
benefit of the doubt or more of the
benefit of the doubt to people who are
part of your team part of your family
part of your community your fellow
countrymen it is a liberal lie and error
that that says that we should not afford
any more grace or trust to our own
countrymen than to anybody else on Earth
it is it is a fundamental political
error that comes out of the lips I'm not
just saying the modern left-wing
liberals I'm talking about liberal
modernity I'm talking about the last
several hundred years that says oh no
all these things like loyalty to family
loyalty to tribe you often hear tribal
politics that's the worst thing in the
world well people are in tribes aren't
they people do come from families and
tribes and Nations and it's natural to
have a kind of affection for that and to
offer some Grace to that the family is a
natural Human Institution and political
communities
progress naturally from that patriotism
is a logical extension of filial piety I
have no problem with with Joy Behar
saying yeah look Biden's on my team and
so I trust him more than I trust the guy
on the other team I wish conservatives
would understand that a little bit
better there's nothing wrong with
preferring your family to somebody
else's family there's nothing wrong with
preferring your country to somebody
else's country
everyone else on Earth operates that way
it's only these these benighted liberals
in the west who have thrown all out that
out the window and said that no human
beings are all just undifferentiated
individuals floating in The Ether
somehow we're all citizens of the world
Kumbaya no that's not true it's not not
how politics works it's not how human
nature Works my producer Ben Davies has
a story every week that he's upset that
I don't get to and so I've got the story
here facing upside down I will flip it
over and read the story for the first
time you got to go to the member block
to do that okay that is dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout you
will get two months free on all annual
plans see at the member block
[Music]
foreign
[Music]